it's time for screen junkies boobie
fights this episode is brought to you by
Good Omens
a new series premiering on may 31st on
Amazon Prime video oh yeah what what I
said what is going on you guys what in
the world welcome to movie fights
hashtag movie fights live
we are live today and this is going to
be and oh my god it's it's all coming
down around us it's an apocalyptic
end-of-the-world movie fight and we got
some awesome fighters but Before we jump
into that I've gots to say hi to hashtag
Ala Nation hoot hoot everybody
Percival's in the house all right let's
meet these yeah I love that picture
let's meet these formidable foes who are
gonna be squaring off in this
apocalyptic themed movie fights first up
you know her from DC daily after buzz
all over the internet your friend and
mine Markie McCarty yeah I'm ready here
to explore the apocalypse with everybody
at this table
let's nerd out and let's see who wins oh
heck yes great oh you know touching
hands I feel bonded yeah second you've
seen her on geek and sundry Newegg and
she's now back on movie fights Hertzberg
I'd like to think that if we all squat
it up we could survive the apocalypse
together I think we could I probably
have to you know kill and eat Greg but
we're all going to fight so no no co-op
gaming today all fighting nice if you
need a guy on that squad who like I'm
not like an explosive expert or a knife
expert but I could say dumb crap all day
long funny guys not funny either of the
squad I'll take it and finally you know
from the real rejects and the reigning
bathroom key holding champion those
bathrooms are amazing oh yeah I was like
this is not the bathroom I'm you see we
should move the set over there yeah it's
the kind of bathroom at like an 80s drug
kingpin very movie Oh Greg albo welcome
back to the party good to see you my
friend happy to be here having beer I'll
keep it brief I like being here I love
everyone here I like you all let's have
fun let's chat my second all of that
deciding today's go around we have the
Dan cam along with myself I got Dan
Merle and Daniel Radford the voice of
the people dan you're gonna be holding
down the fact zone right as always
checking the facts trying to make sure
that we separate fact from fiction
wherever we can indeed and remind us you
got made an announcement last week for
those who the uninitiated who are not
privy to that please yeah give us the
lowdown yes you didn't see last week's
show you can watch this show and then
jump back to last week's show for the
full rundown but movie fights is gonna
be moving off of its weekly schedule in
July not til July we'll be here every
week until July we're gonna be moving
off of the weekly schedule of July we're
going to at least once a month maybe
more it just kind of depends on when we
want to do the show but as a way to send
off the weekly era starting next week
and this was not my idea I would like to
underscore this all of June culminating
on a last fighter standing event for the
belt on July 4th
all of June will be what Billy Business
has has deemed the almost Gotham
tournament I every single movie fight in
June against some of the most fearsome
competitors my greatest foes my greatest
friends in the game each fight will have
a different theme I'm super excited to
share some of those with you but I don't
want to share all of them in Kay Dan
wanna jinx it question I'm will for one
of those fights will you be standing and
get in front of a mirror fighting
yourself well I learned that we should
not stand on the show next week's fight
will be the first my first challenge we
got it's going to be the Battle of the
facts it is going to be myself and
everyone else that has sat in this chair
recently Danielle Radford and lon Harris
the fact checker extraordinary fight
will be next week
it's yeah if you have any questions
about the show and what it means why
we're moving and all that stuff you can
check out the beginning of last week's
episode we go into it in a lot of detail
but we're super excited to start the the
almost Gotham tournament next week and
what it's gonna be it's gonna be quite a
gauntlet do you mind do you feel
confident I know oh yeah we'll see of
course not yeah there may be in this
room other than Danielle who would be
included in this tournament you'll have
to see you'll just have to wait and see
right on Dan oh and the belts on the
line for everyone and every one of the
fights there's a very last yeah weekly
fight will be on July 4th we July 4 dr.
a begins it will be a last fighter
standing which if you don't know how
that it works we bring in a whole bunch
of people and if you want to get to the
end you have to fight your way through
every single one of them and the winner
of that last fighter standing event the
last person standing will be the new
movie fights champion hell yeah that's
all
yeah that's a real mayhem I like it and
sitting next to Dan waiting patiently
the delightful wonderful Danielle rap
for the voice of the people Danielle go
on tell us how that whole thing works so
the way that this works is there is a
poll that is going to be going up on
YouTube it happens as soon as the
initial arguments come in because we
want to make sure you're voting for the
arguments and you're not voting because
you like to pick more and so the way
that that poll works is in the case of a
tie we throw it to the audience and you
guys will actually help decide the vote
there are some fun polls that are
happening on Twitter you can feel free
to join those but they don't count for
this specifically but if you go on to
movie fights live hashtag movie fights
live please give us any alternative
answers any of the dank memes as we call
them yeah and if I see something I like
I might shout you out on the show that's
cool that's cool thanks Danielle all
right now before we get started I
definitely want to thank today's sponsor
Amazon Prime video and Good Omens for
sponsoring today's show Good Omens is an
action filled comedy about an angel
played by Michael Sheen and a demon
played by David Tennant who have formed
an unlikely friendship spanning 6,000
years on earth the apocalypse is nigh
it's coming but they have lost the
Antichrist an 11 year old boy unaware
he's meant to bring upon the end of days
they must now embark on an adventure to
find him and save the world before it's
too late
based on the best-selling book by Terry
Pratchett and Neil Gaiman Good Omens
premieres on May 31st on Amazon Prime
video be sure to check out
those two Diana Davidson attend it
paired together that is a devastating
show is real oh yeah
Neil Gaiman take my money yes money for
a minute I have a crime I could just
watch it there you go
right yeah I'm helping with this Good
Omens on Amazon Prime now you guys wanna
do a movie fighting and that's why we're
here so JT you dropped that sick ass
package
[Music]
hey thanks Thor okay so let the
apocalyptic movie fights begin good omen
today's debate debuts this Friday on
Amazon Prime and in honor of that we
asked what is the best movie about
preventing or surviving the apocalypse
best movie about preventing or surviving
the apocalypse and we start with player
number 1 mark yeah yes ok so starting
off a lot of people like to toss around
the word apocalypse like it's not
supposed to be the end of all days ever
everything wiped out the way that we
know it there's no turning back
and then also concentrating on what is
the best version of preventing this in
case scenario and that movie obviously
is Star Trek first contact this movie
not only prevents the absolute end of
not only the human species but we're
talking galactically everything turns
into Borg everything ends everything and
they are able to prevent this and why it
is such an excellently great movie is
that it's not just a Star Trek movie
this is a movie that even if people
don't like sci-fi or sci-fi fiction or
anything you can still have them watch
it and they love it so yes alright mark
here coming out of the gate with Star
Trek first contact Tricia I chose the
matrix this is fantastic just a
fantastic piece of cinema so when we're
talking about what is the best movie
about surviving the apocalypse I'm gonna
go with the matrix M so when we're
talking about a great piece of cinema we
can say bullet time special effects were
practically invented for this film using
a rig that contained 120 individual
digital still cameras and to film
cameras and then stitching those still
images together to make what has now
been used in sporting events and plenty
of other types of media going forward
they had tons of action sequence
training both the actual actors and the
stunt performers for months and months
and months before the film even started
to make sure the action sequences were
on point it won for Oscar
this is a movie that to this day people
still reference terms like red pill and
blue pill it has become commonplace even
over 20 years later but the reason that
I say that it's the best movie about the
apocalypse is because it has us question
reality it has us question why we're all
here and what happens after in a way
that I feel like a standard action
apocalypse film doesn't even come close
to touching when you delve into it and
really make it a philosophical and
theological question it makes it frankly
horrific and that's why this film sticks
with people to this day whoa you took it
to a deeper level thanks Trish Trish
with the matrix Greg Turner to Greg Alba
what do you guys terminator dark fate
yes build up my answers so yeah
Terminator 2 is my pick and this movie
to me manages to be a wide variety of
things it's a blockbuster action film
it's a sci-fi film with commentary on
the relationship between humans and
technology and explores themes of
sacrifice survival and even love and
while it's making sure to be a film
that's not just plot driven but heavily
character driven and a lot of these like
really heady sci-fi films can be
entertaining they can be exciting and
they can be thought-provoking but none
quite do it as well as keeping a
relatability core with its characters
it's very iconic characters might I add
it's exhilarating it's intense with its
action scenes its effects still hold up
to this day it's at times menacing and
scary it's intelligent has a lot of
heart and there are iconic scenes that's
still to this day when I watch it I am
moved to tears and at times it's also
really funny and I guess the reason why
I chose this one was because I love this
film a lot because even though it's got
a lot of big things on its mind
underneath everything it's all in
service of the characters the characters
goals throughout are about preventing
Judgment Day and along the way the main
characters have complete arcs and
they're like totally different people by
the end of this movie and because of the
mission that they set out on to prevent
the apocalypse they walk away with a
deeper understanding on the value and
hope that lies within
humanity so Terminator the rise of
machines right on it Terminator 2
Judgment Day three awesome movies fight
it out please okay so for Star Trek
first contact out of the three movies
that we've said and uh these are awesome
movies I love rewatching these movies
all the time but out of the three
mentioned the only one that actually
solidifies the approach of preventing
the apocalypse is Star Trek first
contact because matrix not only is it
not prevented it's just like in progress
we know that there's two more movies and
even the end of you know the the third
movie is just everywhere
um agents are let go I mean they're
they're just off into the wild uh
apocalypse is not prevented Terminator 2
we know that they tried they did not
prevent the apocalypse they postponed it
and we know that and the absolute next
movie because everything goes to crap
and rise of the machines
so with preventing the apocalypse Star
Trek first contact is the only one that
actually accomplishes that I would like
to point out that the question is the
best movie about preventing or surviving
the apocalypse and the matrix is most
definitely surviving the machine
apocalypse how are humans still moving
in this world so I do not think that
that disqualifies our two answers if
we're going to go into what makes you
into what makes the best film because I
agree with you Mark II I I do think that
these are all excellent choices they're
all movies that I personally enjoy so
it's very hard to sit here be like this
movie's not good because that would be a
lie coming out of my mouth but the
things that I will say as far as what
we're talking all good which one is the
best for Star Trek first contact I would
say that I don't think it deals with the
why with the what comes after as well as
the other two and because of that way
doesn't feel like a like a real threat
to like to me well cuz think about it we
know the force of the Borg and we have
run into this numerous times before this
movie happens so they are completely
successful and eradicating the Borg not
only in the past but in the future
because they eradicated the board in the
past when they went back to
to do that so how is it that you're
saying that this isn't a great movie for
preventing and then also surviving the
apocalypse because if you want a second
layer on it the earth is in a type of
stasis where they have to survive
numerous like it was like new killer
winter and all these land wars and
everything and so they are surviving
what they thought was the apocalypse the
board come down to deliver the actual
apocalypse and then the intrepid crew of
the Star Trek Enterprise actually end up
preventing that so it prevents and
survives and it's a kick-ass sure thing
about Star Trek though that I feel with
first contact I think that is one of the
best movies in the franchise I don't
think I think that's a fact I don't
think it's one of the best I don't think
it's the best movie and I also think
that was actually the first Star Trek
movie I saw in the theaters and I didn't
watch the shows or anything and if you
don't have the pre-existing knowledge of
the show I think I'll give you that I
think it works better as a mainstream
movie than most of the Star Trek movies
however I still later on I was still
like detached for a lot of it and I
still didn't really fully appreciate it
because I was very evident while I was
watching it that this feels like I need
to have watch the show in order to
appreciate this movie and I think it's
also a film that probably could have
gone deeper Star Trek is really known
for it's like you know xif eye
explorations and that movie kind of I
feel like sacrifices a lot of that to be
more of a popcorn action fun film which
it is it's really fun it's really
entertaining and thrilling but I feel
like in terms of exploration of the
effects of the Apocalypse I don't really
feel that there and as far as the matrix
the matrix is actually my favorite
Terminator 2 and the matrix are tough
for my favorite movies so the thing
though with the matrix of why I prefer
Terminator 2 is the matrix to me is very
thought-provoking
it has a lot on its mind but not a lot
here and if it was for those who are
listening I'm pointing to my heart right
now
it's it's not very emotionally driven I
think it's it's a lot of exposition it's
a lot of world-building and it's really
cool like it's a cool movie but I don't
really feel that much investment
in like a character journey there's
nothing in that's really gonna move me
to tears there's nothing in that's
really gonna get my pulse pounding other
than wow this is really interesting this
is really fascinating this is some cool
philosophical world building whereas
Terminator 2 I think kind of combines
actually both element I think about it
combines both elements I think of what
your movie provides over my movie
provides of like as far as all more
movies also deal with artificial
intelligence to a certain degree but
what Terminator 2 I mean bringing it
back to what you were seeing with Star
Trek first contact with having to set up
world building you chose a sequel within
a series so there has to be a suspension
of belief and a jumping over hurdles
that has to happen to be able to get
into that world anyway while with Star
Trek first contact I mean you have some
powerhouses in there you have Sir
Patrick Stewart you have alfre woodard
as Lily I mean you you have these like
this these powerhouses that are
establishing this world for you this is
extremely character driven not only with
that but with the technology is easily
accessible because you have Lily as the
interest into your world
she is likable she is fierce but she's
also she's standoffish until she
embraces the world while when you look
at that for these other two movies I
mean like I said movies movies but like
with matrix you have neo and he's kind
of he's just kind of blank and you kind
of have to paste yourself onto him yeah
he's the everyman which has been a huge
key stone of storytelling since the
Greek made the best choice matrix is
more of an observant piece I feel yeah
it's a fascinating observant piece I
love it and you mentioned earlier matrix
not having heart or anything that kind
of brings emotion into it for you I
think quite precisely because neo is
that every man that we can all put our
own selves into we go on this journey
with him to find out what is humanity
what makes most humans besides our
intellect you guys this is a great
conversation great 10 beta I'm enjoying
the heck out of listening to it but
let's shift gears to final thoughts and
we'll start with mark eeeh okay so
oh yes this is all about what is the
best movie about preventing or surviving
the apocalypse
like I said Star Trek first contact hits
both of those you you have an
established community that you feel that
you are a part of even if you don't know
the Starship Enterprise and their crew
you feel like you are a part of them
it's because of the actors is because of
the cinematography it's because of
everything wrapped together that you get
involved you are not only preventing but
you're also surviving the apocalypse at
the same exact time I literally cannot
think of a better movie out of the ones
that we've chosen to be able to show
someone no matter the age range to be
like hey this is what we can do we can
survive we can prevent this is how we
roll the apocalypse
thank you Mark eeeh Trish when we talk
about a wonderful Apocalypse related
movie whether it's preventing or
surviving I think some of the things
that make it hit home for audiences
everywhere are that the apocalypse could
be something that we brought on
ourselves through our own failing and
our own journey and we can see how that
realistically happens and then it's even
more of an excellent story if it's a
story that we can then save ourselves
from and I say we meaning humankind so
what I will say against Star Trek first
contact is that it's an alien invasion
that's something that's out of our
control so I feel like it just doesn't
make it as weighty of an apocalypse
story what I will say about Terminator 2
Judgment Day which again I love that
movie I do feel like you could argue
that maybe something is lacking and that
it's a machine that comes to save us
it's not we who find the solution and
save ourselves the matrix is the one
film where yes we've got this great
philosophical question we can clearly
see how we've gotten to this apocalyptic
future where we are just being used as
batteries and we don't even know what
humanity is anymore and then we find it
within ourselves to break free of this
apocalyptic artificial intelligence that
we're in and find out what that core
thing means of what it is to be human
and what it is to survive and live we
have all that in the matrix plus we have
the philosophy plus we have the amazing
special effects plus the performances
plus the cinematography plus the action
sequences matrix is hands down the best
apocalypse pill Thank You Trish
great for terminator 2 yeah every time I
gets brought in a lot well I think the
matrix is certainly iconic I don't think
it holds up as well as it once did it's
thought-provoking it's mind-bending but
the emotional experience is kept at a
distance even like with Trinity and neo
in the movie it just feels cheesy now
and forced and not burned I think when
you get to some of the effects to are
still good but there's a lot of them
especially with the Sentinels that just
look really bad now and Star Trek it I
still do believe it requires other show
like a show in order to really be
invested into it and you brought the
point about how this is a terminator -
this is a part to Star Trek first
contact is raised the summer Trek at
that point and James Cameron
intentionally made Terminator 2 where
you don't have to watch the first one in
or he specifically stated that and I had
seen Terminator 2 at least three times
before I ever saw Terminator 1 and I
also think both your movies actually ate
a lot of Terminator 2 for a reason if
you look at the matrix it's about
finding the chosen one in order to save
the world against AI and if you take out
the characters or Trinity neo Morpheus
you pretty much got the t800 Sarah
Connor and John Connor and the liquid
terminators like the agent Smith
character and I think my characters are
much more relatable more emotional have
a lot more iconic scenes like that scene
when Arnold at the end when he
sacrifices himself
neo is superhuman program Jesus in that
movie right and so you're I don't think
it's a detriment to say it's a machine
that saves us when at the end of
Terminator you cry for that machine if
there's a father-son dynamic there's
this beautiful iconic performance from
Linda Hamilton a Sarah Connor in that
movie and I think with Star Trek first
contact they definitely ape the time
travel element of having to go back in
time to save the world against this AI
so when I think of an apocalypse context
bring it back to the question it's a
cool theme because the apocalypse
affects the human race each and every
one of us it's you know it's a more
inspiring note to me for a movie to end
on not super Jesus or people of the
enterprise yet again save the day but on
how we work together as a whole that's
the whole point of Linda Hamilton's
closing speech and so yeah I mean I also
think there's also a gray area that they
explore with the
all our films deal with technology and I
think there's a great area that's
explored with not all technology is
going to be bad at the end of the day
what matters is how we are as a
collective as a species as humans and
Terminator ends on that button time all
right wow this was wonderful yeah good
stuff everybody brought a game Dan
Moreau what's going on the facts oh yeah
I was just doing some checking I
couldn't find the signal from James
Cameron saying I probably made it I just
it's hard to find about not having to
see the first thing he did he did make
Terminator 2 purposely and puzzled about
who the villain was which was them
giving away in the trailers and the
commercials making that whole first 30
minutes
pointless on his part unfortunately
that's the dangers of marketing kids
luckily the franchise only did that
every other time they made a couple Star
Trek things the the question of the Borg
saving not just earth with the galaxy no
concrete evidence that when the Borg
traveled back through time they traveled
beyond Earth although you could it could
be supposed that they did but so not a
confirmation but not a denial they're
just something that's not stated
explicitly in the movie and then the
Borg while the Borg that traveled back
through time were defeated the Borg
themselves continue to exist in the
future of the Trek franchise notably in
Star Trek Voyager and some other places
the Borg Queen came back for some TV
appearances so those specific Borg were
killed in the past but the Borg
themselves in the future lived on and
continued to be foes of the Federation
dan Murrow and one of the preeminent
Star Trek fans I know thank you sir okay
so this was a slam-bang
knock-down drag-out debate you guys
again it's entertaining to be privy to
it I'm lucky to be sitting at this table
but so but we got to come right get down
to brass tacks and pick a winner here
yeah so AM archaea I loved your choice
and I think it's brilliant but I felt
like we leaned a little bit into some of
the semantics of the question about
preventing or surviving and how your
movie was relevant to that but we didn't
go as hard at it being the best
overall film so at the end of the day
came down to Trish and Greg for me and
you guys were trading blows non-stop my
favorite movie so I was like yeah you
branded a couple of hay makers at the
end there with like some of the FX don't
quite hold up some of the performances
are a little bit stilted now but Trish
you just listed so many great qualities
of the movie Greg you were swaying me
but then I felt like your argument
focused a little too much about the
heart the soul and the meaning of the
film and you didn't hit the bombast
enough the effects James Cameron's
action sequences are some of the best
I've seen in my lifetime and there's
from freakin what 92 or I probably got
that the euro but so because your your
argument was so centric to that and
Trish hit the effects the philosophy and
various elements of the film that
brought it for Oscars just by a smidge I
gotta go Trish Dan mm yeah it was tough
for me too but I went a little bit of a
different way I love Star Trek first
contact is probably my favorite Star
Trek movie you're up there my first two
or three but not for the arguments it
was between Trish and Greg for me and I
was I was I was very I was leaning
toward Trish for those same reasons she
definitely heaped on the fact that it's
beyond just the apocalypse and and the
characters but the cinematography the
effects and everything like that was a
very compelling argument but for me in
the end Greg won me over with the idea
of tying it all around this fact
first of all defending that he defended
his movie very well the idea that like
no it's not just a machine it's it's
using a machine and the the progression
of that character and what it meant and
about humanity about about human nature
I thought you'd really put into
perspective the ways that the apocalypse
itself wasn't just an event that it was
used at in a larger sense in this in the
movie his closing actually did a lot for
me
- landing those for me so my vote
actually goes to Greg I think but it was
it was not an easy decision they're very
very good arguments all around right on
okay so got one one danielle make some
sense of this right let me go ahead and
refresh so i can get the top alright at
61 percent of the vote Terminator 2
Judgment Day matrix 10% for first
contact some of the other ones that
people were mentioning document got a
lot of love Shaun of the Dead this is
the end next a lot of people City Road
you would have yeah did you fix on the
road yeah I'm I to pick the World's End
oh this is the end is so damn funny that
one deserves love I was also thinking of
children of men good I saw your thumbs
up Danielle that's all that matters
right oh yeah as he's sinking in yep
alright so Greg is up one nil nil Trisha
Marky Oh looking to get on the board
here's question number two alright we're
gonna have some monsters at the theaters
this weekend Godzilla king of the
monsters
kaijus are back opening this weekend
what franchise should do a crossover
movie where the heroes have to take on
Godzilla what franchise to do a
crossover where the heroes should have
to take on Godzilla question - let's
start with player - Trish I feel like
this is an out of the box pic and so I'm
gonna have to fight uphill here but I
went with stranger things having a
stranger things crossover with Godzilla
obviously this is something that kind of
people have been having fun with and I
know I've been having fun with online
because Milly Bobby Brown is in both of
them so like what would happen if I
loved a fantastic underdog protagonist
when you look at movies like then ever
any story the Harry Potter franchise
anytime you have kids that have to save
the world it sets you up for a wonderful
film that audiences everywhere will
enjoy so having this specific cast of
characters have to go
against Godzilla we have already seen
them tackle two different monsters from
other dimensions so they are familiar
with dealing with the monster mayhem the
11 has tons of abilities because I know
people are gonna say they stand no
chance godzilla survived a nuke what are
you even doing Church dad they're all
your your a promoting child slaughter
because that's what's going to happen
movie however based on what we know
about Elevens psychokinetic abilities
I'll use that word they're linked to her
emotions so should her friends or anyone
be in danger that's gonna explode out
and become even more powerful
she's got ESP telekinesis telepathy
portal manipulation to the upside down
dimensional travel technopath ii
psychometry bio Kinesis and potentially
teleportation so i do think that they
would stand a chance and they've got a
nice party and a nice adventuring party
of characters with the heart and the
brains and the defense cautious one and
then the opie chick coming in with the
super power so i think it would make a
fantastic film
alright trisha promoting child slaughter
with stranger things Greg what do you
got all those definitions about Elevens
powers I'm like yeah I know what all
that yeah I actually saw a Godzilla king
of the monsters recently and it has
pretty much the same issue that I feel
most of these monster movies have which
are boring crappy cheesy human
characters right mark eeeh I saw that
look I will talk about Godzilla
afterwards and thinking about this
question I wanted to go with something
that we could see blended but also not
be obvious and still lend itself to an
instantly appealing character so I went
with the Evil Dead franchise right off
the bat you get a wonderful leading
human character in the form of Bruce
Campbell as ash and even though it's had
its movies it had its ash vs. Evil Dead
show I think I still think you could
pick it up after the events of the final
season of ash vs. Evil Dead and I like
this choice because while you got this
wisecracking alcoholic smart
he's battled all kinds of supernatural
creatures but he's never battled a giant
he's never battled like a kaiju or
anything like that
enormous before and I think it would
lend itself to a hard-r horror comedy
which i think would be great for this
these big monster films the human stuff
usually feels corny or boring and they
often have humor that just lands flat
and the great thing about the Evil Dead
franchise is that when it's cheesy it
works
that's rare quality and these monster
films need to be scary and the other
side of evil that it's a horror
franchise it's it can do both for
Godzilla and my basic like really quick
plot idea would be that Ash's retired
with his friends now chilling in Tokyo
and then one day
Godzilla emerges which forces Ashe to
have to find a way to defeat this
Godzilla so I'll have to do the one
thing he'll he's never had to do before
work with the evil death or the
Necronomicon I call it action the Evil
Dead versus Godzilla all right thank you
yeah around the horn to mark eeeh okay
well uh one thing that I have a lot of
respect for Godzilla Godzilla movies yes
they can be campy but one thing that I
don't like is that when Godzilla is
nerfed and if you have their major if
you have Godzilla and I'm using they
just in case it's not oh you know with
with Godzilla you've got to have a
really good hero or heroes going up as a
foil against this immensely powerful
creature keeping in mind Godzilla
once upon a time when they were nerfed
had a black hole hit on them and
survived so if your hero can't take a
black hole your hero can't take Godzilla
but I also understand about having the
appealing characters and having a
franchise that people can get behind
along with having it be powerful enough
to take on the beautiful beasts that is
Godzilla so that is why I chose the DC
EU and specifically in the DCAU I chose
Swamp Thing
Green Lantern Jessica Cruz and Shazam
reserving for as I get into my talk with
other people from the DCU but then in
particular small thing because Swamp
Thing is all about balance of the green
balance of nature the green versus the
black versus the red and Godzilla
depending on the origins that you're
coming from which which one that you're
doing it from is a type of apparition of
nature so therefore Swamp Thing would
want to balance that would want to
justify that balance Swamp Thing is
immensely powerful depending on which
run that you go with with that with
Green Lantern what Jessica Cruz she
would she would come out and show out
and you have her willpower and her
structures to add on to that along with
this for the approachable franchise you
have Shazam which you have the shows
Amelie so you have and I'm just gonna
say super Freddy is super Eugene super
Darla you have all of them so you have
that beautiful like touchstone of Shazam
of the Shazam Lee you have the horror
aspect of Swamp Thing taking on giant
gazelle along with green lantern Jessica
Cruz taking on with structures I in a
sense to add on to this Warner Brothers
in legendary have making the new
Godzilla Warner Brothers as DC you I
don't know why this hasn't been made
already I want to see it right now
alright a match made in studio heaven
right there fight it out everybody all
right I don't want to kill children
yes you say Shazam and you become a
superhero a superhero family as a person
you have one person and if anything
happens to her and we can even see at
the end of season two stranger things
like she she like pops out herself like
she is like out for the count nosebleed
like out she can't take on Godzilla and
the rest of them are literally kids what
are they gonna do rat bottle rap battle
Godzilla it's not hot would you have
Milly Bobby Brown like it she's already
in Godzilla king of the monsters that
this is following up king of the maybe
they're twins separated at birth and
they find connection but I would say
that yes we have seen that 11 takes a
little bit of a hit when she uses her
powers however we've also seen from
season 1 to season 2 her powers are
getting stronger and she's taking less
and less of a hit and her powers are
more sustainable each time so it serves
to believe that they'll live forward
again she's taken down two monsters from
other dimensions already and she has the
ability to travel into other dimensions
who's to say she couldn't put Godzilla
in the upside down and game over and
that's how they all work together to
figure it out because she's not one
person she's got a team in addition to
the other kids in addition to Mike and
Dustin and Lucas she's got Joyce Harper
given that mother's love into the film
she's got the anti you know defeat you
know the detrimental Ness of the public
education system sure she's got like you
know the stuff that she can do but like
against a giant again you guys are
missing the link where Elevens powers
are tied to her emotion so that's why
I'm harping on the emotion with the
other characters now if we're gonna talk
about who can or cannot defeat Godzilla
Godzilla survived to nuke some RKO and
you were like DC EU I was like alright
Superman
yeah I got this Wonder Woman yes she got
this but you picked something yes this
is Angela
and Jessica Cruz where have we seen that
any of them have nuclear capabilities
the Shazam family definitely has that
absolutely and not only that Swamp Thing
most definitely does
The Swamp Thing cannot be killed
literally spores from Swamp Thing ended
up on the moon and he was able to
regenerate from those he can't and he
can multiply in size and in strength
because he is literally a force of
nature my thing with this for heroes
taking on Godzilla is that not only does
it take these particular heroes to then
put them more into the mainstream it's
able to do the powerset but keeping in
mind
I didn't just name these three I said
the DCE you so as the movie progresses
yes I am going to bring in the Justice
League
giant arch-nemesis of Godzilla Ghidorah
shows up I kind of had a little bit of
an opposite reaction to you where I felt
like there will be limited conflict with
if you're gonna be if the show's Amalie
is pretty much a Superman character and
like you saw him be v and the DCE you
I'm not talking compos like the DCU you
see Wonder Woman Batman and Superman
defeat doomsday I think if you have
Green Lantern the Shazam all those
Shazam characters Swamp Thing it to me
it doesn't really lend itself to a movie
that will have real stakes I feel like
you and especially if you include the
Justice League in there because it's
just gonna be like I doing too much it's
all - everyone's hating Godzilla it's
the same let's all see the same kind of
movie just instead of kaiju you just got
other people demonstrating their powers
it's not all of them against Godzilla
like I said it's the arch-nemesis might
keep mispronouncing his name is Ghidorah
Ghaderi and that's the three-headed
Hydra like the super arch-nemesis it's
like once the Shazam land and keeping
mind that you have like by that time
they're like oh I don't think we could
take this we tried Darla's like I
thought it was fast enough but I'm not
I'm sorry I'm not a good
yes sir I mean like yes you are and
Eugene you know hits with behind the
Hadouken and you have that you have
Swamp Thing with this angsty Shakespeare
thing and all of them coming together at
Green Lantern with a Jessica Cruz
holding down Godzilla and then they all
they're all battling them and it's like
oh yes we won and then here comes you
know the three-headed Hydra and they're
like oh crap
and then it's like they have to actually
bond with Godzilla to take on that
three-headed Hydra because keeping in
mind that Godzilla movie it's it's the
Titans like they have so much more they
have Mothra in there they have them I
think they have a rodent in there so
they have a lot more than a great ton
from you about evil dead since the
opening at the other thing with these
movies is like stranger things does lend
itself to I obviously a crossover with
Godzilla I feel like would be I feel
like it would be a fine Godzilla movie
but it wouldn't be a satisfactory
stranger things movie I feel like you
totally lose that and with these
characters I'm like we've seen these
heroes battle big giant super villains
it's just this is a different version
now within the form of a kaiju with Evil
Dead I think you get something totally
different for the Godzilla franchise I
imagine you could do a sequence where
the the Deadites then what they do is
they infect humans and the Deadites can
infect like take over Godzilla
so you essentially have like a Godzilla
dead-eyed in there and you can do that
with other guys you as well and one of
the fun things is with the way they
always taunt ash in it so you could have
like this weird kind of scary comedy
where you got these Kai's you who are
also psychologically taunting ash
throughout the film and I even would
borrow a little bit from that or then I
could roll in everyone as bad but I
would like kind of correct it a little
bit where gods over Godzilla does have
some babies and then he has to fight all
these other different kinds of Godzilla
babies throughout it would just be wacky
and weird and fun whereas the stranger
things yeah I've seen them battle
monsters before it's just Anna to me I'm
like whenever you take a TV show and
make it into a movie it's not
satisfactory stranger things works
because it's a TV show
each light time shift gears and go to
final thoughts Trish
final thoughts for me are that a you
said Ashe would be retired so we go in
like the Mission Impossible 4 he's like
oh man I got to do this I'm so old now
also you said it yourself that he's
never battled a monster before so that
presents problems and you also said when
it's it works because it's cheesy in
relation to the Evil Dead but you said
that of the other movies don't work
because they're cheesy you said they're
problematic because the heart makes them
the characters are too cheesy and
underwritten so I'm just pointing out
that crossover we did we talked to mark
eeeh we talked to Marquis quite a bit
about which DC EU characters are gonna
be in there and when you say the Justice
League was going in that I'm gonna say
Aquaman's to Opie why can't he just
mind-control Godzilla and then it's end
over a game of movie all right yeah end
of game movie so I'm gonna again going
with stranger things because as you
actually pointed out Greg earlier in the
argument one of the things that makes a
lot of monster movies and action movies
kind of fall flat for people is that
they have very two-dimensional
characters two-dimensional character
interactions and romances or friendships
that we don't necessarily buy believe in
or care about stranger things we already
have that chemistry again we have the
underdog protagonists that people are
going to be rooting for and marki you
brought up a film that everyone can
enjoy everywhere when you have kids as
your protagonist this is a film that
people are going to be enjoying
everywhere whether it's a scary Godzilla
monster as long as kids know that kids
can defeat it
nightmares none nightmares no one kids
can defeat it Greg I'm not exactly sure
what you were talking about the under I
didn't think I was talking about I don't
recall exactly saying that I was
mentioning that the monster films they
take themselves really serious and I let
myself some unintentional cheese I think
when you're intentional about it you can
still have nuance and layers and one of
the cool things about the Evil Dead
franchise is whenever you catch up with
ash he's at a different point in his
life and there's something about the
Evil Dead that always brings him out of
retirement and that's an element that I
would want to toy around with because
the Evil Dead always bringing him out so
I think it would be fun to have
be forced to try to work with the evil
dead in this movie and I also think that
unlike your guys's movies mine could be
a hard-r like Godzilla actually going
around destroying cities killing people
it can be violent and very gory menacing
scary there could be a lot of wacky zany
nough sin cluded I I think you could
have this like weird [ __ ] until I get
to quote like something Bruce Campbell
would say like [ __ ] in finale where he
warrants on some spell with the
necromancy connector of my necronomicon
necronomicon that's how you say and
where he makes himself with his
boomstick shotgun is his chainsaw and he
makes himself a giant where he has to
fight Godzilla one-on-one and you could
be cracking some silly bruce campbell
tongue-in-cheek jokes you know about
like size of certain things or whatever
just seems like the same bruce campbell
sarcasm throughout which would be a
total blast to see stranger thinks to me
that works like we saw what happened
with Game of Thrones when they condensed
it into six episodes it was rushed
unsatisfactory and stranger things will
fall prey to the similar thing if you
have all these characters one of the
best things about stranger things is the
fact that you get to have multiple
buildings you get to have multiple
character explorations that span over
the course of many episodes you try to
condense a stranger things journey into
one movie it just will not satisfy it
will feel like a rushed TV one-off
episode and for the DCE you going up
against Godzilla I just have a hard time
seeing how there's a real conflict there
even with what Churchill just brought up
with Aquaman controlling the monsters in
the ocean you can control Godzilla just
so it would just be another like hidden
movie that's it it's another superhero
just punch a movie and but not really
anything ATS I just don't feel the
stakes with your film when I feel like a
three of them are enough to take down
Godzilla you don't even need the whole
Justice League to do it alright thank
you Greg mark here uh so Godzilla is an
apparition of nature so Aquaman cannot
control him that's not a it's not a
possibility it's not even on the table
so also with having the Shazam Lee that
hits the kids note of being able to be
on board with like that level of it but
then they
so turn into superheroes the reason why
Swamp Thing Green Lantern and Shazam is
specifically Jessica Cruz Green Lantern
which is a newer Green Lantern were
chosen because their power levels would
actually machen be a good battle for
Godzilla the actual Justice League
coming in later is when the three-headed
Hydra comes in and there's the whole
Titans thing I know you haven't seen my
movie yet but that's that's how it is so
but with when I think I am so tired of
like camp eNOS with it with Godzilla I
want a monster movie I get my my comedy
and my fun from the people on the ground
for the people that are battling
Godzilla not through him and I need for
those people to be able to be heroes
enough and be powered enough to be able
to actually make me believe that they
can take him on and that they can win
until even bigger threat you know comes
up and then it's like oh now they're
bonding with Mozilla because yeah we're
it's pets they're pets to then take on
this greater threat so that's why I
don't want an ash in there because just
this is just not enough power
even with Deadites it's just not enough
power for Godzilla to then also do the
rest of the Titans that are that always
seem to follow Godzilla in general so
yeah let's have lesser-known DC EU
characters continuing with the extended
universe with things because it doesn't
all have to be connected it just all has
to be fun and powerful
alright time good stuff you guys
dan please take us to the fact zone and
then give us your thoughts on this
question sure the the black hole gun or
weapon is from the year 2000 s godzilla
vs. mega guy wrists I'm sure I'm not
getting that from Association direct but
yes they were they they shot miniature
black holes at Godzilla he was able to
extricate himself from one and destroy
it with his atomic breath so the
question of Aquaman I have devoted a
healthy amount of the last part of this
the question of whether Aquaman could
mind-control Godzilla is a very
interesting one because Aquaman's mental
marine telepathy has been used in many
ways over the years it used to just
marine animals for a while they said
that because humankind shares an
evolutionary chain with marine animals
then he could do certain things with
human beings there was a time where he
could do stuff with Superman but then
the new 52 refined it a little bit more
I that I did find there was a creature
called topo which is a kaiju size
creature that Aquaman did use his mental
telepathy in telepathy to control
however it was such a strain on his mind
that it put him in a six-month coma but
marki actually I think opened up the
gray area in that argument that needed
to be opened up which is that it seems
like it's always based on nature of the
fact that he is able to to connect with
animals in the animal kingdom the fact
that Godzilla is an aberration of nature
by by his origin hood I think factually
negate Aquaman's marine telepathy so I I
have to say it's probably very likely
that Markie is correct in that it's it's
unlikely that Aquaman could could
manipulate Godzilla telepathic well I
love this train of thought
oh sure okay please yeah I'd stranger
things just never quite in for like 11
versus Godzilla yeah I love that like
the power of a strong mother is it's
great but I just don't know how that
would do it's Godzilla yeah choice is
hard I love her heart but I just don't
know how that would match up to go so it
was between Greg and Mark yeah for me
and I think yeah and I love that I love
that take with ash and and the but but
honestly the the Godzilla has little
Godzilla's and then ash was fighting the
little guy that was too much I know that
you tried to diffuse the grace to
instill 98 for me and Mark you did a
really good job talking about how and
the different powers would interact in
the future where the franchise would go
I would I would go I'm going with Mikey
on this one I think that it was it was a
factual a strong argument and and I
think I asked is such a good idea but
I'm vibe that much I'm going with more
key right on okay so that's one for mark
Kia yeah I feel similarly as far as the
stranger thing so I'm sorry yeah it did
feel like 11 versus Godzilla
I feel like a lot of the stranger things
stuff we get and I think those kids
would end up kaiju food and it came down
to mark iya and Greg for me and oh man
that image of giant ash going up against
Godzilla is pretty epic
but everything else like it became kind
of a little bit too much for me there's
so much sewing that's fair yeah there's
a lot going on there and I love that
tone but I don't know there's something
that spoke to me I don't know it's
totally different but your description
of all the heroes versus the kaiju and
Godzilla reminded me I don't know it
took me to an old team-up of GI Joe
versus transformers
back in the eighties like these big
things and these little guys and I don't
know it just took my mind but I really
liked it just I like the nuts and bolts
of your of your movie of your pitch and
I could see it happening I'm also going
marque after so marki gets the point
yeah Danielle what the polls say oh just
barely
it was 38% for the Evil Dead 37% for DC
EU 23% for stranger things a lot of
people were really wanting detective
Pikachu mostly just detective Pikachu
but they just really want rodent to get
squashed and then also a lot of votes
for Captain Planet you know I would
watch that they both have that
environmental message so yeah that that
makes some sense Thank You Danielle all
right so I didn't help
Marcius got one point Greg got one point
Trisha trying to tie up this ballgame
and we go to question number three so
between Good Omens and Godzilla if the
apocalypse was upon us we asked what
movie character would you want leading
your group of post-apocalyptic survivors
who would you want leading your group
and we start with player number three
Greg when I thought of this question I
was thinking specifically about
leadership with this okay so I actually
picked someone who I've argued for on
this on this show before Ethan Hunt from
the mission impossible franchise I think
it's easy to choose a character who's
the most badass who's the most lethal or
a survivor which I do think he actually
has all those qualities which have been
demonstrated throughout the franchise
he's been shown as a constant survivor
to like you know crazy danger every
Mission Impossible movie he's forced and
pretty much every movie to go rogue or
whom he's by himself or he recruits a
few people along with him who are
practically facing their own
self-contained apocalypse was there a
risk of dying all the time by being
rogue he's always being thrown into
insane harsh conditions where he's
forced to figure out a way to survive or
keep someone else alive and he's
demonstrating I think this is very
important he's incredibly good with
people
he's loving and you actually really
need that in a leader you need someone
who refuses to lose or sacrifice someone
else for the greater good someone who
can give you hope while facing the
impossible he's clear he clearly has
training and studying and dealing with
human beings in a psychological sense
which will come in handy when you're
dealing with strange folk in a
post-apocalyptic world you're gonna get
some crazies out there you need someone
who knows how to handle those kind of
people and I also think that with its
IMF training and this is a really
important thing to me about leadership
too in my three is shows that he was a
teacher at one point he would be great
at teaching people how to survive in the
apocalypse a great leader doesn't only
show up to protect you he doesn't only
show up to make sure you're you're safe
and look after you he has to be able to
instill enough skills and you that if he
happens to not be around you have enough
skills obtained from him where you can
still survive so to me in terms of
leadership he's the best pick
Ethan Hunt mission impossible leading
Greg's pack mark iya who you got okay so
the movie character that I would want
leading my personal group
post-apocalyptic survivors I want
someone that does not rely heavily on
technology someone that is able to stand
on their own two feet that can go up
against any kind of technology that you
can throw at them that has been at the
level of like people that you wouldn't
think would be able to survive in the
first and the first like two months
forget the first six months I was
someone that was at that level and then
grew into an epic lethal badass that not
only has contingency plans while they're
alive has contingency plans for after
they're dead to take care of the people
that are left behind and that is why I
chose Sarah Connors and actually I'm
really glad that the first round went to
Terminator 2 because Sarah Connors is
the best picked for survivor she was an
elemental force and Terminator 2 and
keeping in mind that is just bridging
the gap from Terminator like the
original one to that sequel having her
be the leader of a post-apocalyptic
group it's like that keeps me warm at
night you know that's like that's warm
milk during
collé night right now because she would
shape us and that's the thing that you
need because none of us are hard enough
to survive we think that we are she
would show us the way and she wouldn't
get tired of us she wouldn't leave us
behind Sarah Connors all right mark you
know going with Sarah Connor Jordan
Connor Sarah Connor yes in the first
Terminator he was going through the foam
but there were multiple Sarah Connor
ended up with poor fates mark Kia thank
you Sarah Connor
Trish again I went outside the box with
my picks for this one I did not show
crazy from an epochal a traditionally
apocalyptic film yeah um I decided to go
with Aragorn from the Lord of the Rings
franchise because I specifically for
leadership qualities like Greg mentioned
earlier I mean who has greater
leadership qualities than who ultimately
becomes the king of the next age he also
has survival skills he's a ranger he can
live off if there is no technology he
can not only live off the land and
survive it but hunt and track for new
sustenance he can pass on his skills to
others Greg mentioned passing on skills
and leading the next in training the
next generation as we saw him do with
both Mary and pip in the films he has
amazing diplomacy skills so not
everything has to come to blows because
he's a good dude and he's got heart
again he's a he's a great leader because
he's the leader that doesn't want to be
the leader as we know because he took
the name Strider and Thorin Gill many
times to not have to face that he is the
heir to rule because he doesn't want it
but that's precisely why he's the best
one for it again not power-hungry at all
he's also númenórean so he has a much
longer lifespan than a normal human so
as far as worrying about dissent amongst
the people after he goes you've got a
long time to figure out that game plan
and in what we know of the Tolkien verse
when he becomes king that is the end of
the Third Age and he rebuilt all of
middle-earth into a time and land of
peace and prosperity which if it's the
apocalypse
and you're trying to figure out how to
survive after you want someone leading
the way that can build back up a
survivable livable functioning society
and Aragorn can do all of them alright I
love how different these three answers
are fight it out guys the thing with
okay honestly Sarah Connor was the first
name I wrote down when submitting my
answer the thing that made me not go
with Sarah Connor was because she I
think she'd be a great soldier and a
great person to have on your team in
terms of the great general in terms of
being a leader she's wildly emotionally
unstable movie when she's trying to get
out of the psych unit she tries to keep
her composure she loses it when she well
the thing with miles Dyson
she totally totally went against what
they were had planned went after
attacked and nearly killed Myles Dyson's
family in the process of it and sure she
had a change of heart after she shot him
a couple of times but she's someone who
has demonstrated several times that she
does not she's not good with people and
I think a leader needs to be good with
people she me a good like Daryl but she
wouldn't be a good Rick garage she is
not a daryl that is oh that's not a
really good analogy to do for Sarah
Connor and then keeping up mind since I
brought in the first movie with it I'm
also bringing in rise of the machines
because I did mention that also I'm
doing a Sarah Connor in the movies like
guests that we know of so there is a lot
of growth that happens to her from the
first to the third and like I said
before I mean keeping in mind how both
look how all three of our characters
started off Ethan Hunt was kind of can I
say douche he was kind of you know he
was practically an adulterous playboy
that was a you know playing around on
this team and then that's why he was the
scapegoat for it because he was are you
talking about the first I'm talking
about the the first mission a possible
are you or are you talking about a
specific group if I'm talk
movies like Gaston yeah I mean in the
beginning piece of Congress there but
down the road yes Connor so we're
talking all about also um so so with
that I mean and keeping in mind like I
already said relies heavily on
technology heavily like I do not see
this dude just surviving against well
let's say zombies are like the
wilderness in general he needs like
masks and he's trying to jump out of
planes we don't know if planes are gonna
work and everything there and then I'm
talking about I'm Aragorn uh Eragon
sorry
Strider yes and like medieval last time
with like orcs and stuff I can see that
but with like the post apocalypse that I
was picturing was the one that we would
be existing in in present day and yeah
guns exists what is dude gonna do
against ur dad I mean seriously it's
gonna be like a 13 year old kid that's
just gonna take Aragon Aragon out I use
gonna be like why are you pointing this
thing boom okay and he's gone Oh have
you seen elves use ranged weapon trained
by the elves and you actually said in
your and your opening that Aragorn
doesn't want to be a leader and I
wouldn't want that guy to be my foremost
so most Lord of the Rings of ego
Mortensen just seems like depressed and
doesn't want to be into it and you want
someone who's caring and you like feels
like confident in what they're doing
well instead of feeling like huh fine
I'll do it
difference between saying fine I'll do
it and saying I don't want this
responsibility because this is an
immense responsibility I'm thinking
about people other than myself which I
would say for both of these yeah this
one has a question to make sure we're
playing completely fair here you're
talking about bringing Aragorn from
middle-earth into like our if we had a
post-apocalyptic situation like at us we
had an apocalypse it was from a
different world middle-earth into
bringing them over here or it could be a
post-apocalyptic situation there well
because if it's here in whatever I don't
think he will work as it's a different
landscape and environment the question
is what characters you want leading your
group of survivors work here okay great
I would say that he is skilled in many
many many different areas and again if
we're talking here where it's supposed
to apocalyptic situation where say
there's no more electricity or there's
no more fuel and people have to survive
off the land and go back to that and
what are orcs if not medieval zombies so
if we're talking zombie apocalypse right
now then we are right there in the game
that is what this man is trained to do
now when you have people that do rely on
modern guns on modern explosions if that
is taken away from them and they don't
have that which in so many
post-apocalyptic films those things are
very scarce and we do see people
battling to get those things because
they're not readily available when
gasoline has run out when explosives
have run out then I do think that
Aragorn stands the best chance out of
all of these people and you guys are
talking about not wanting to be with
someone who doesn't want to be a leader
Aragorn does not want to be the leader
because he cares too much about other
people and doesn't want the
responsibility if something horrible
happens to them he does it precisely
because he's trained to do exactly those
things and therefore is the best of it
because there's no power dynamic that
comes into play with Sarah Connor she is
specifically out there it can be argued
for personal and selfish reasons that
she's looking for her own family the
world let's shift gears go to final
thoughts Greg started off yeah I mean in
terms of the technology argument we're
dealing with our world so while there
might be scarcity and stuff we'll still
have things like cars we'll still have
things like guns we'll still have these
things in our world in a
post-apocalyptic situation that
characters like Sarah Connor and Ethan
hunter you sue and Ethan Hunt has
demonstrated several times he's not
maybe he's involved with like there's a
plane or something but he's not always
using technology in early on in the in
rogue nation there's like a six-month
period where he's on his own it's that
weird moment where he grows a beard
nobody he's by himself not being
technological reliant on IMF stuff he's
pretty high in mission
- even he's mountain climbing without
anything just as just his own hands he
can do things without relying on
technology Sarah Connor
I'm gonna stick with it she is very much
an unstable she's someone who gets very
emotionally reactive and can make poor
decision-making she even pushed away her
own son who was meant to be the leader
of the most important human being she
pushed away from this whole journey and
so I don't have faith in her Ethan and
Aragorn I were in a very different world
very different kind of people it just
wouldn't be the same kind of society
granted I think in a post-apocalyptic
situation people devolve it still
wouldn't be in tune at all with what
Aragorn is used to and he doesn't like
being a leader Ethan Hunt he's
demonstrated being later at its best I
think to lead people it's 20 percent
physical 80% psychological at least and
he's demonstrated that has the most a
mental and emotional endurance he can
properly pass on he knows how to
properly delegate or utilize the peak
because if you got to work together as a
unit and he knows how to inspire people
and properly delegate tasks here and
therefore if they have to go on any
missions to stay alive he knows how to
work systematically he knows how to plan
things you know how to improvise if
things don't go wrong these are all
elements demonstrated throughout the
film and another really important
quality is this level of self-confidence
that he possesses clearly rubs on to
whomever is following him Sarah Connor
yes she might toughen you up but she's
not good with people she wouldn't be
someone who would make you feel like
better about the future have some hope
aragorn's always kind of you know gloomy
totally even hunt
he's someone where people follow him
into the impossible for a reason he
knows when to be stirred and knows when
to show appreciation
so yeah just that's basically my final
thoughts on it thank you Greg around the
horn of Archaea okay with um Eragon
there's just too much acclamation
involved with a post-apocalypse that
would happen with us now America will
have guns we still have TNT there will
still be plenty of fuel at the beginning
of the post apocalypse and it's like
having the tootisha suit seriously he
shows up here all I'm thinking is like
backwoods you know hillbilly our
backwoods outdoorsmen it's like
not going to follow him I'm not he
doesn't know what's going on and he
smells and it's just weird it's just
waddle with with Ethan Hunt this this
pretty boy dude that it's just like I'm
not gonna follow him either he's he's
he's a loner that keeps a very very
small network of people around him he's
going to go into the mountains with just
being Rimes and the really funny British
guy was at Simon Pegg uh yeah he's
that's that's who he's going with he's
he's going to take them and what he does
is that he gets people that are
followers to then you know be with him
while with Sarah Connor out of the three
of us she she's the one that grew from
our stock she was where we are now she
knows that she is in it for to stop the
apocalypse she is in it to save our
world the way that she does that is that
she makes leaders and it is established
in movies I guess that and you're just
focusing on the second movie of Sarah
Connor but it's established that she has
a network of people that she relies on
she is a general of a revolution she
went from being a waitress into being
that I mean and there with rise of the
machines so not only is she would she be
adapt at the technology that we would
have which would be fuel guns TNT and
such as such as she would know the best
places in the country because homegirl
had to travel all around everywhere to
keep in front of the machines to keep
John Connor safe
she knows that people are our future so
she would invest in the people unlike
what technology and wouldn't like trying
to figure out this world and I will be
king of you it's like that's not a thing
that we want that's not a thing that I
want to follow with my leader of my
post-apocalyptic survivor group all
right some say children our future she
says people are our future Sarah Connor
Trish Aragon Aragorn never said I will
be king of you that line is not dead
in fact he doesn't want to be king I I
can go on and on and on about the
amazing skills of the Aragorn but I
figure I'll close with that let me just
start out with Ethan Hunt because I
didn't say a lot against Ethan Hunt I do
feel like Ethan Hunt intentionally in
the first gosh 5 Mission Impossible
movies doesn't have much of a
personality he's kind of vague on
purpose he's just this guy with
borderline superhuman skillset he can
hold his breath for longer than three
minutes and get through explosions no
problem not bharanam
and that that's what's so fun about
those movies not necessarily his heart
his care for the rest of humanity and
his leadership skills I do think he's
very capable but I don't know that
people would follow him because he'll be
a good leader after whatever the threat
is taken care of or whatnot when it
comes to Sarah Connor I don't buy into
the she's emotionally unstable argument
but you started out your argument by
saying that she doesn't need to rely on
technology and then you went on to say
how good she is with explosives and guns
and she has been trained by really
criminals all over the world so my
question is if we are in an apocalypse
where technology is scarce what is she
going to do that I mean that is though
that is the only skill set she's trained
in and she is ultimately looking after
her own but her own safety and her own
family
whereas Aragorn you guys knocked his
skill set you tried to knock his skill
set down but let me just remind you the
things that he is skilled in
swordsmanship horse riding hunting
stealth field medicine and tracking
skills which in any apocalypse film
those are like the primary things that
like how many people in our world
currently can fire a firearm even if not
well most people can how many people
have field medics kills how many people
can train how many people can move
stealthy how many people can track those
are skills that are gonna be the valued
hard-to-find skill set choice is why I
want those in a leader again he's not
power-hungry at all he's the leader
because it's put upon him in
he's the best trained for it not because
he's power-hungry he's able to train hit
the people who follow him and give them
new skills to better survive in this new
world he does have a númenórean lifespan
which i think could be very important in
this film and the biggest thing I'll say
is that he completely rebuilt
middle-earth after the end of the Third
Age to completely rebuild society after
everyone has lost all hope
that's what surviving the apocalypse is
about BAM all right quite a Throwdown
dance how are you really trying to
nominate some Dan tickets the facts own
well it's weird because my factual
things kind of tie into my my my
judgement on the round alright so yeah
give us the whole kit and kaboodle then
please well it really comes down to
largely Sarah Connor for me and her role
in the film's because I thought marki I
had a really strong closing but I think
the facts are a little off because Sarah
Connors is is not in she's dead she died
prior to rising the machines and what we
find out she basically went into
seclusion and kept training John after
Terminator 2 but then died shortly
thereafter we learned a little bit more
about her there's the TV show and then
whatever they're gonna do is her in dark
fate but I really like Mark he is
closing but I don't necessarily think we
know that about her from the movies for
what we know because she's she's gone by
the time rise of the machines comes up
so I had to sort of pull back on that
angle and looking at it there's
something that Greg actually said that I
think he was trying to use to bolster
his argument but I think ended up
working against him which is when he
said that it's it's 80% psychological
and 20% physical when he's talking about
Ethan Hunt but I think that that
actually works best for Trish's argument
and honestly I also it seemed like so
much of the argument it gets airborne
was about guns and guns and technology
and guns and guns and guns and like
that's one point but they seem to be
like 80% of the argument against aragorn
whereas Trisha made a very good I
thought compelling argument about
leadership quality inspiring hope
rebuilding like these are all
of the apocalypse as well so I think
largely because of her arguments and
also because I felt like so many of the
arguments against her we're focused on
this one element whereas I felt her
argument to be a lot broader my vote
goes for Trisha and Eric one that's one
for Trish yeah I thought they were
compelling arguments from everybody the
Ethan Hunt argument he's he's got such a
skillset but then I I think it might
have been Trish that said that he felt
like it was just like a human guy yeah
and yeah so it came down to mark eeeh
and Trish for me
yeah it's we're dealing with this
general she's also a survivalist and
Marcia touched on how she's like
journeyed across the country being
chased by terminators and Trish but
Trish gave us this like a really stellar
breakdown of these leadership skills
that would be tactile but I feel like
we're I felt like that was a huge blow
though the fact that he's from another
time and just the simple acclamation to
this world and we're dealing with one
kind of apocalypse there could be like
who knows what the access to machinery
and cars guns will be in this
post-apocalyptic world so that is not a
finite element that we're dealing with
so the results of the poll are in and
Trisha with Aragorn takes the point
so that means oh this is a great moment
in sports is a three-way tie we're going
to the tiebreaker folks and the
tiebreaker works thusly so I will ask
the question shout out your answer then
you'll each get 20 seconds to elaborate
and the order we heard your answers and
then in the same order you'll get 10
second rebuttals okay very similar to
the speed round here is the question
what movie character would you entrust
with preventing the end of the world all
by them
de marmol Superman Captain Marvel
Superman Christopher Reeve Superman
Superman b54 Tony Stark
Tony Stark okay cap Marvel Super Man
Tony Stark
it's Trisha Greg then mark eeeh
Trisha twenty seconds begin when you
speak taking advantage of that I see not
a straddle write down my 22nd Superman I
went with Captain Marvel because I feel
like she is the obvious choice to this
answer Captain Marvel is so incredibly
overpowered we find her even difficult
to use in films because she has such an
enormous skill set
she is the protector throughout the
known universe whereas I feel like some
of the other characters that have been
picked today do not have such oh people
great I mean it's Superman he's faster
than both of these guys he can fly that
all his powers he but you see in
Christopher Reeves Superman movie the
first one that you know when there's a
problem he could just go spin the world
in reverse and reverse everything if
everything's going wrong he has pretty
much unlimited of abilities in this
capacity where I think Tony Stark yeah
he did a good thing an end game at the
same time he is just a human being who
just had to be the one to do it
we don't know what kind of apocalypse
that we're going to face what if it's a
viral one you can't throw power on that
which you can is that you can throw
genius sacrifice and money you can throw
Tony Stark on that and if it is a power
thing he is also Iron Man and he will
take that sacrifice for the team just
like we know that it has already been
established so no matter what the
apocalypse is Tony Stark is the best man
for the job and he's hot ten-second
rebuttals Trish starts they were screwed
Tony Stark only really has power here on
earth so if the apocalypse is starting
anywhere else he can't charge Jarvis he
will eventually run out Tony Stark
nearly destroyed the world by building
Ultron Captain Marvel has a lesser power
skill set than Superman a super mega
just listening into the space and go
home who has some good idea if there was
a virus thing and he can find the right
guy Captain Marvel is too busy with the
rest of the universe she always wants to
go to other planets Superman has
kryptonite
and you can't go up against Lex Luthor
Tony Stark will build a gal Friday Tony
Stark will build another Jarvis Tony
Stark is here for us time all right now
it is Dan Danielle and myself our jobs
to pick who unfortunately does not move
on to the speed round Danielle I found
that I thought that these were all
really good arguments obviously everyone
at this table is very good at fighting I
unfortunately I'm gonna have to say that
mark 'ya would not be moving on okay
that's one from Archaea not moving on I
thought mark his argument was strong as
far as Tony's intellect and that might
win the day for me I thought Greg edged
out Tricia
because it came down to those two super
beings and just he made the case for
Superman's superior skill set so for me
would be Trisha dan I would advance mark
eeeh first because I agree with the the
thinking which is that both Greg and
Tricia just threw power at it where
the nature of yesterday it might require
intellect whereas Tony Stark brings that
that advantage so Iowa advanced marquita
so they became between Greg and Tricia
which is essentially a power battle and
I felt like Tricia made the argument
that Captain Marvel is extremely
powerful but I thought Greg brought to
bear exactly which powers Superman would
use how he would use them to counteract
certain effects so in the in the power
battle I think that Greg employed
Superman's skill set more specifically
and to the question the interested with
Captain Marvel so I would advance Greg
Greg mark you you're going to the speed
round Tricia you fought like a G
valiantly nicely done and sadly others
the only two can move on to the speed
okay let me just get out my popcorn yeah
yeah the you guys have all done this
before it works the same as the
tiebreaker that we just did I'll ask the
question calling your answers 20-second
answers and then ten-second rebuttals in
the order that you answered it is tied
1-1 that did not count for a point so
one one tie here we go question one of
the speed round what director who has
who never has should make a movie about
the end of the world
what directors never made a movie about
the end of the world to me
five four three
this is ASMR 3mn it's two and a half two
david fincher david fincher two one and
a half David I think that's how you say
his name Lynch yes okay we have live to
David's Fincher Lynch and Greg we heard
you first a David Fincher twenty seconds
begins when you speak can you repeat the
question before I go yes sir
what director who never has should make
a movie about the end of the world the
end of the world is a really weird
concept I'm Lucy David Lynch do weird
before I want to see a director who
brings this is sort of out of his round
like it actually blend in well with what
he does
David Fincher excels at psychological
dark thrillers and when you're dealing
with the apocalypse you're gonna deal a
lot with this psychology the psychosis
of how people aren't evolving and kind
of turning on each other who's trying to
get each other yeah why don't you the
end of the world I want something that
is r-rated huge but is also darkly
comedic and and brings that because
that's that's what it is it's like it's
the end of life as we know it it's like
the end of our lives I want the end of
this to be something a Deadpool like I
need for it to be a splash grotesque but
also funny and breaking the fourth wall
I don't feel like Lynch is like Deadpool
like we're Fincher he can bring that
r-rated element - have you seen his
movies or movies like seven and such are
very violent films and I think more
importantly you'll get a character it's
not just the movies along with this
Lynch is that you get that character
aspect of it where it's it's it's darkly
funny but it's also incredibly
vulnerable and personal and that's what
I want for an indoor old movie and
dan where do you stand on this well I
want to bring up a point of order
because I think we might have had some
cross wires here okay I give if I
understand you thought that Markey was
argue for David Lynch correct yes Markey
your argue for David Leitch the director
of Deadpool yeah I think we're at cross
bottom so I might thank you Wow yeah I
would take 10 more seconds for each for
Greg to co-lead like he I think to
respond to that no no it's it's I think
it was just the the leech and Lynch are
so close every I made an assumption that
everyone else was talking about
something different so yeah I think just
maybe 10 more second scene and thank you
so I leashes the Hobbes and Shaw
director and yeah he's not chance to
help yeah
and directed the second dip oh yeah yes
yes yes yeah whatever great I got you
guys 10 seconds together you're talking
about elements that David Leitch has not
brought to the table as a solo director
Deadpool too as funny Hobbes and Shaw is
ridiculous but these are qualities that
he's not demonstrated he knows how to
make fun campy action films well that's
about it whereas day David Fincher Luke
delivery oh yeah we're talking about a
director that has never done it but has
the elements to it when we see how the
scale that he can do like he did in
Deadpool 2 but also have the comedic fun
with it like he could do time-travel he
could do just giant things that come
here and take us on all right Dan I
think ultimately going by the approach
that everybody everyone brought to it I
feel like I've seen some dark some funny
it gets to the director like and and for
me the argument I made the most was the
the specifically what the director
themselves would bring to it and I think
venture one out for me Clawd like mark
has more of an approach and I think I'm
more about why David Fincher himself
what he would bring to it so I would go
with Greg was very very even for me
right on Danielle you know mix up and
everything aside I thought that there
was some there were some great points
for Fincher I do agree with the dark
thrillers and talking about the way that
you know psychology would go into it I
did think that other than just
mentioning you know some strengths and
some set pieces she mentioned how
besides being funny it can also be very
vulnerable very personal Bowl along with
having a big scale so I'm gonna go with
murky that's one one yeah at the end of
the day I really just whetted my
appetite and got me that much more
interested to hear this the dark
psychological journey about the
apocalypse so yeah just barely I gotta
go Greg and Fincher so Greg gets the
point there
and it is now to one with question 2 of
the speed around upon us which movie
post apocalypse will you rather live
through Mad Max or Waterworld
Mad Max okay Greg has warned world we
should have answered fast okay
marquita twenty seconds begin when you
speak
I prefer to live in a Mad Max apocalypse
because we already have people that
survived desert climates we know how to
battle this technology we know how to
battle wind storms and everything like
that um beings do not you must do not
just live in water we don't we don't do
that for like wet water world in general
having to like recycle our own pee and
only live on boats that scurvy of the
highest order I think well especially
fury road really demonstrates that it's
easy that living in the desert that you
would easily dehydrate you just starve
it's harder to find food whereas if
you're living on water a that's pretty
cool it's different be your ease it's
easy you're not gonna go thirsty see
you're also gonna be able to go fishing
or that whatever kind of secret all the
things that you struggle with you're not
gonna have that same struggle with with
the madman in a Mad Max rebuttals one of
the major things that water world says
is that it's salt water you cannot drink
salt water water water everywhere but
what am I to drink while with a duster
survival Mad Max like I said that we
like the assumption that we have the
cars we have the technology
everyone in Mad Max is just like evil
and trying to hurt you you can't trust a
single human being there or at least
some water world if you got a Kevin
Costner on your team man you are
protected you are safe man Max is just
like danger left and right all right
water water everywhere
that point for me that was that was
poetry yeah so that's one damn yeah it
was close to me until the rebuttal and
then it's like well I think Mad Max
would also be someone who's BAM mark you
you just tied up this ballgame or no
question number three Dennis Hopper
unless you wanna trade okay if the
apocalypse are about to happen what one
movie would what one movie would you
save to enjoy in the aftermath for the
rest of time five four three Shaun of
the Dead 2 the man who knew too little
Shaun of the Dead man who knew too
little
we heard Greg first Greg twenty seconds
we can when you speak what's great about
Shaun of the Dead is that it gives you
hope while you're certain likes having
it deal with an apocalyptic situation
and your sue mean you're not alone in
this apocalypse you're able to remind
yourself that as long as you have your
friends as long as you have some family
things can be okay while this apocalypse
is happening the man who knew too little
is like comedies like that all they are
is like kind of funny but they don't
really work everyone if I'm living in
Apocalypse I don't want a movie that
reminds me of an apocalypse because I'm
already in one I want a movie that has
Bill Murray and it's really great where
it's like I and you can also say Society
and all of its foibles and just you can
really warm in that like blanket that
the man who knew too little can give you
while Shaun of the Dead it's funny but I
don't want to see zombies when I'm like
starving in a cabin well Shaun of the
Dead has a lot of levity and I think
it's it can actually be beneficial to be
watching some that you could sort of
relate to in your real life but could
bring hope to your real life where's the
man I knew too little that doesn't
really bring any extra nuance and the
jokes would get old very fast fun
rewatch
along with the comedy of the man who
knew too little I will actually have
these really great comedic performances
that are going to be in it I'm gonna
have you know Boris they're gonna have
you know like I said Bill Murray it's
all right Dan what do you got oh that's
tough because they both made really good
arguments like they were both founded on
a really solid ground as far as like do
you want to be comforted or do you not
want to be reminded of what you're going
on yeah ultimately I think I'm going
with Greg I thought that was great to
punch against the idea that you may not
be reminded that you're in an apocalypse
it was also the idea of like hope and a
situation relatability I think I think
Greg made the better the stronger
argument that's one for Greg yeah I I
went the opposite way I that really
spoke to me not mine to be reminded that
you were in this dire straight by
watching a movie about a dire
circumstance over and over again so I'm
gonna go with the light-hearted fair of
the man who knew too little and Mark
eeeh Danielle if only and this for me it
wasn't either one of those like it
wasn't about that or that the warm
blanket versus dealing with the world
Greg brought up something that is
unfortunately super true about comedies
if that's all you're watching for a
lifetime those jokes are gonna get so so
old and man that knew too little whereas
with this Shaun of the Dead I feel like
those jokes are gonna get kind of old
too but since it is something that you
can relate to that might be one where
it's like oh that thing with the dogs
that happened to me yesterday so because
of that I have to go with Greg Greg
moves into the lead 3 to 2 this is game
point for Greg mark he needs to needs it
to take it to it another tiebreaker here
it is which end of time scenario had led
to better movies which end of times
scenario has led to better movies alien
invasion or zombie outbreak we're
talking about like the genre and in
general yeah which has spawned better
films the an alien invasion scenario or
zombie outbreak scenario alien invasion
okay Greg you of zombie outbreak mark
Kia 20 seconds begin when you speak five
four three a lien of Asian movies have
led to better movies because not only
does it take the hope that we have as a
planet but it's like we have an other to
go up against so then we become even
better for it and then along with that
with alien invasion there the scientific
and the cinematic leaps and bounds that
have happened with that from
Independence Day to say five four three
the zombie franchise has led to just
much better more personal films alien
invasion movies are always the same
alien attacks we gotta find a way to
survive where a zombie films focus a lot
on the heart the survival elements I
just brought up shaun of the dead that's
all about hope the George Romero
franchise all those of the Dead movies
like five or six of them are most of
them are pretty fantastic films World
War Z epic when we're talking about
better movies we're talking about
pushing the envelope zombie outbreak
films tend to be more be movies they
tend to release on like Netflix or they
released like and he's like on shudder
it's it's smaller but will like better
movies you happen bigger is not exactly
equal better I mean Jim Jarmusch is
doing a new movie with Bill Murray that
is a zombie movie and zombie land for
example is it as a big movie but that's
also a wonderful film you haven't really
listened to any alien movie though
posted several i'm i thought mark he had
some lovely points in her opening salvo
but then greg hit just but the heart and
then he gave specific examples that won
me over I gotta go Greg on that Danielle
oh yeah so with this one um I
unfortunately I loved murky his argument
but as soon as she said how you know
zombie movies tend to be tend to be
smaller and not quite as grandiose as
soon as he wound up being able to bat
that away and name some
were bigger like a zombie land that did
that for me it was just like barely but
it was just because of that counter so
right Greg
you just took movie fights well but you
got us there you took it home Marky oh
well fog oh yeah
you guys very entertaining Greg go ahead
and say whatever you like my friend I
love watching these two specific like I
watch them all the time on the Internet
and so basically when I watch when I was
doing this match specifically and I had
a moment where I got pulled out and I'm
like this is one of the reasons I just
love watching movie fights like there
are times where we do get a little bit
intense but I really feel like we're
just having a great movie discussion you
both are so freaking funny and yeah I
just love being I loved I really really
love doing this fight with both of you
this was great seriously yeah where can
people find you oh yeah yeah the real
rejects on YouTube and at the greg alba
on instagram and twitter good stuff and
i ii what you say I'm just being privy
to this good stuff oh it's fun yeah I'm
losing it like when I lost I liked it
actually
Trish you're always so smart and funny
please tell us yeah tell us some things
well yeah thank you guys so much for
having me and absolutely well thought to
my two competitors today Greg is one of
my favorite people to fight against
always for the good vibes and the
positivity and the first time we fought
against each other we then had like a
Twitter conversation for the next three
days about the movie fight I think it
was amazing oh I'm so movie fights we
fight but then we all become friends
after it brings us together so seriously
thank you guys for having me again thank
you Mark II oh you fought brilliantly
and if people want to find me online
they could do that at that GRL Trish on
Twitter and Instagram and Facebook and
on YouTube and twitch slash Trisha
Hershberger alright mark here great
stuff your comic knowledge you always
drop like some nugget where I'm like
damn that's it
and just great stuff today please tell
us where we can find you know like let's
start yeah absolutely and I want to
continue the conversation with you oh my
god y'all that's this was really fun
yeah so yeah if you have a DC Universe
it's a subscription service at DC movies
comics and TV I'm a host on there a DC
daily so you can check that out Monday
through Friday and also you will find me
like around Nerdist doing random things
so check out there but if you want to
connect on the Internet
then Twitter and Instagram at Merck and
McCarty that's ma RK e I am C CA RT Y so
yeah thanks mark eeeh Dan it looks like
we this weekend we have a rocket man vs.
Godzilla who's gonna win that battle
weather sound like a movie yeah we'll
see it's gonna be it sounds like it's
very likely gonna be Godzilla because of
the size of it but you know how will
people react to the reviews reviews of
it a little for it but that doesn't
always stop a movie Rocket Man Bohemian
Rhapsody did so well is they gonna be
alive enthusiasm and then you got MA out
there oh yeah baby Spencer holding it
down so it's gonna be very healthy
weekend at the box office yeah it would
be shocking if Godzilla was not the
movie that was no yeah it's a crazy
weekend cuz though there's three movies
that I've seen Godzilla already and I
absolutely want to see those other two
that you mentioned Daniele such a great
fight cuz these fight it's always
interesting to see the way the fights
are different depending on who you have
on and this was definitely the Deepcut
fight yeah this was great I mean really
happy for me you know keep watching all
the movie fights and the commentaries
and I just did the evolution of Captain
America you can go check that out also I
have my wrestling podcast tights and
fights comes out every Thursday and
follow me on Instagram and on Twitter
yes
everybody here and please follow me how
al are you d ni ck on Instagram and
Twitter for just o fun stuff dumb stuff
just idiocy and an American tournament
of nerd oh no we're off because of my
I'm getting married soon
my my three dogs and that I have with my
fiancee will no longer have to watch us
live in sin thank you for throwing it
down this was such a blast Thank You
Billy biz Thank You jte and thank you to
our sponsor Amazon Prime and Good Omens
check that out May 31st and thank you
for watching all right
this episode was brought to you by Good
Omens a new series premiering on may
31st on Amazon Prime video